Do you ever wonder what sets apart confident positive people from those who feel insecure and pessimistic
It's not a matter of winning the genetic lottery
Instead it's a matter of self. Love if we don't take the time to appreciate who we are
It becomes second nature to put ourselves down instead of building ourselves up. Are you wondering why you've been so down in the dumps lately?
Here are eight signs of emotional self-harm You should recognize
One: you run away from your emotions
Do you often reject reality for what it is an escape with drugs, alcohol ,or shopping sprees?
It's perfectly normal to be afraid when we're stressed out about life
But don't run away from your emotions when they're trying to tell you something
Dr. Stephen Stastny believes that feelings are more physiological than psychological
They send action signals to your muscles and organs, which prepare your body to do something
you need to heal. when you don't confront your emotions, you also run the risk of putting off your psychological needs
Some questions you can ask yourself are why am I feeling this way? And is there anything I can do about the situation?
It's good to recognize the things that upset you so you can understand them better through self-reflection
Two: you are ashamed of who you are
Dr. Lynn Margulis says that shame underlies destructive behavior. It's an awful experience
The individual goes when they feel bad about themselves
Unlike guilt which is propelled by our conscience after doing something wrong. Shame is actually more dangerous
Because it doesn't need to be situational. When you feel bad about who you are
You also start to believe that you don't deserve a healthy relationship
Support from your friends or a job that fulfills you when in fact you do
Three: you belittle your own progress and accomplishments
It's one thing to never grow comfortable and continue setting goals
But it's an entirely different story when you don't give yourself credit for how far you've come
You're hurting yourself
When you bask in emptiness after working hard to achieve something instead of two getting the time to practice gratitude for your own hard work
One way to appreciate yourself is remind yourself of one thing. You're proud of each day
It's also good to take some time off to relax and look back on how far you've come in the last couple of years
This can prevent you from being too fixed on fulfilling the next checkpoint and be grateful for your prior achievements
For you internalize your conflicted emotions
This is different from avoiding your emotions
you know what's bothering you but you refuse to get help from others when you build walls up whether it's being dismissive of therapy or
Alienating yourself altogether from your family friends and partner. You're only taking a bigger hole for yourself
Dr. Breen brown highlights the importance of vulnerability which is the ultimate driving force of happiness.
In the long run, it's good for your health when you become more open and trusting
Five: you constantly feel bad for yourself
William Shakespeare said it best pain is inevitable suffering is optional
It's okay to feel sad and disappointed when things don't always work out the way we had hoped
But when you sulk in self-pity, it doesn't change the outcome or help you get better
Instead of jumping to abrasive conclusions. Like I deserve to feel bad or be punished take a further step and ask yourself
Why you're beating yourself up?
Bottom line you always have a choice. So make it a worthwhile one
Six, you don't prioritize taking care of yourself
Do you practice bad habits, like skipping meals smoking not drinking enough water and consuming alcohol
Research shows that all of these can trigger and worsen. Your anxiety peer pressure sucks
It might seem cool and harmless when everyone else is getting drunk every weekend or sharing a pack of cigarettes
But when it comes down to your emotional well-being
You won't feel good when you crawl into bed late at night and wonder how things got so messed up
surround yourself with supportive
Motivated and confident individuals who are passionate about life
Although it's good to let loose every once in a while
Being around people who exercise hell the habits can remind us to stay focused on our goals
Seven: you are self-sacrificial. Are you a people-pleaser? Do you have a hard time saying? No when others ask you for favors?
Helping others can be fulfilling but not when you are always going the extra mile that can leave you Moody stressed and exhausted
It's okay to cancel plans and take occasional days off if you feel like you need to stay home and recharge
You deserve to feel appreciated, too
Eight: you refuse to let things go
Holding grudges is the root of all misery
It's okay to be mad at someone if they lied or cheated you after all you trusted them, right?
But when you let that anger persist instead of actually trying to resolve the issue at hand
You ignore your ability to regulate your emotions in a healthy fashion.
Dr. Frederic Neumann calls this exaggerated willfulness
He believes that this is what causes some people to commit crimes such as shooting a stranger when they cut them in line
When you only think about yourself, you're not necessarily thinking about the consequences of your own actions
Do you resonate with any of these signs want to know what being emotionally healthy looks like
Check out our video here to learn about the subtle signs. Thanks for watching